[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new tip 2019 interview I am so excited
to be talking to the group behind the
new movie guest of honor so a lot of
people out there are not gonna know what
guest of honor is so I have to do this
and Adam I'm doing it to you can you
give a brief explanation of what happens
in this tree what happens in this movie
there's a father and a daughter they are
yes and he's doing a great job with this
David plays Jim who's a food inspector
who would come into a place like the
restaurant were in right now and
actually have the ability to close it
down if he finds anything wrong he takes
his job very seriously and he's very
troubled by his family situation because
his daughter is in prison for a crime
she may or may not have committed and so
he's haunted by this idea that he might
be responsible for this and he's trying
to work it out as she's trying to work
out what it is it's got her there Rossa
plays the bus driver during a school
trip where Liza who is a music teacher
at a high school is taking her band on
this trip and various things happen
which may or may not have landed her in
jail and then after this wonderful
gentleman passes away she goes to visit
Luke who plays a priest and Jim's
character is asked that his funeral will
be at the church that Luke is now
governing
and they have an exchange which becomes
the spine of the story that's the
simplified version well I mean you tried
like there's five different time periods
and but we're trying to tell it's a it's
basically the story a love story of a
father to the daughter and trying to
understand and and then trying to find
some way of connecting over you know
something that's a piece of history
that's but they have different
interpretations over and and and the way
that ripples through the story so four
years since your last feature hit
theaters I believe what have you been
doing between now and then what was the
key to getting the green light or maybe
taking that time to develop the script
well I I was also like I'm an opera
director and I do theater so that was
but really this was just I was trying to
find the right way of telling the story
like Jim was this was a character I
think he's unlike any other character
anyone's ever seen and so is Veronica so
trying to find the right tone and the
right shape to it it's just you want to
make sure that it's right and it's it's
it's challenging to make films like this
now so I was just so thrilled that I was
able to assemble this cast and that we
were able to tell the story with no
interference and I was able to tell it
exactly as I wanted and I was able to
have complete freedom and they all were
so inspiring to me in terms of the
performances and what they were able to
bring to these characters because they
are unusual characters they're all
crossing lines including Luke certainly
Ross's character they're all you know
crossing a line of something they
shouldn't be doing so they're all
breaking some laws in terms of their own
conduct and the code of behavior so I
wanted to make sure that all of that was
like well harnessed and and and then to
find the right task that takes a while
as well I was reading the press notes
for this and often it is brought up what
an exceptional actors director you are
so the goal is who can make Adam blush
the most right now what is it that makes
Adam GaSe stand out okay I'm plugging my
ears whoever would like to go first
well I'd say for me personally it's one
of the main reasons I did the whole job
was to work with Adam has been a huge
fan of his work for so many years and
then but not knowing much about Adam
himself and then meet him in London and
thinking I will he's a very cool guy who
I can communicate very easily with and
have a real rapport with which turned
out to be true I just think he's one of
the one of the very very very best
directors for performance because it's
actually what a lot of people don't know
out there in the world beyond this
business is that it's quite a rare thing
for a director to really go into talking
and articulating about the character and
giving one new ideas for how to do
subsequent takes and now to dig deeper
than one has in one's own hotel room
wherever you are and for that to happen
live on the set is is massively unusual
and this guy is one of the very best in
my whole career all these experiences
are new but I would say Adam just sees
right through you he will tell me how I
feel and you know develop the character
with me and change it from my own
personality and I was just amazed I was
able to see right through me and I feel
like that really helped and our
rehearsal process was also amazing we
did a lot of that and we improvised
scenes that weren't in the film as the
character and I thought that was
incredibly useful because when you start
shooting you're just very much ready to
go I I think for myself a lot of times I
just find that I don't know if it's how
I got started you know in the business
but I find that I'm kind of always in a
hurry always trying to you know make the
day or get the shot before the Sun Goes
Down and I think that that's kind of
just gotten woven and how I work and one
of the great things about Adam was how
he slows things down and it does have a
very thoughtful process and will sit
with you and not just give you direction
but he'll also ask you questions which
is always very interesting and I mean I
could feel myself inside having to kind
of settle in and
- to listen to such kind of good ideas
in such a different way of working my
character has very little time on screen
but he has to make a certain impression
I had a lot of questions and an Adam was
one of the rare directors that I've
worked with who was actually very
embracing of ideas
I was shocked really because I came with
a bunch of notes and and very generously
he he got back to me without that that
that fear that I usually get from
directors well you have to massage in an
idea but he's just here he just took it
all in and and it's a very unique set to
be on because he works with with people
that he's worked with throughout his
career and and so there's this this
silence this disrespect where it sits
but people people work with with the
amount of love and respect that you hope
for in a film but but usually you know
there's got to be a guard telling
everybody to shut up but but everybody
does it naturally no he's a he's a gift
of a director was one of your your
biggest notes or like most burning
questions about your character before
jumping into it my character plays a
pivotal role in the story but he's he
was very much a means to an end kind of
a character he was he was there to move
the story along but it was I was trying
to find reasons for the the things that
he did when I when I showed up on set
the first day there I was there in the
makeup chair and and they were having
their laughs I was I don't know if I
could swear on this but I was I was I
was the [ __ ] in the film and it's not
at all the way that I perceived them and
luckily luckily Adam felt the same way
so it was just a question of bringing
humanity to again to the guy and and you
know your job as an actor is to bring to
bring a bring breaths in between lines
and just bring things to life and he he
held my hand through it I it was it was
it was one of the special special
experiences in my life
David I want to ask you a little bit
about the food inspector part because as
someone who grew up in New York and just
with I have a little bit of an obsession
with eyeing the signs is there anything
about that profession that you learn to
play this role that really surprised you
I learned there really are some
disgracefully badly kept kitchens I very
careful with it
it's a job I knew nothing about at all
innovate was one of the things that rack
to me to the the story because I thought
well that's a very unusual idea for a
character somebody I don't know why it
is but it seems just a strange job to
put into a movie and then it was rather
obviously quite clear what should be
researched in terms of playing a food
inspector and it's it stayed with me to
this day because I'm very now conscious
of the things I did learn in terms of
what our transgressions and and even
more so my wife who has tried to close
down a few restaurants since making the
film because she's probably out there
doing that right now but it's yeah I
think it's not something we really think
about is it a food inspectors and I
think that's one of the beauties of the
character is it's something that that
drives the plot but is I don't think
he's ever been explored one of the only
people who wants like an entire movie
about a food in school this things to me
was that job I mean it's like you go to
movies and you see like a fireman or a
cop or you you don't or or a chef but
you never see something like a food
inspector and it just had me thinking
about kind of Raymond Carver characters
and I can remember moving from from
Dallas Texas to Los Angeles and for the
first time seeing these letters up in
the windows you know a meaning it was a
good kitchen and then you know finding
out you know that Abby was actually
pretty bad a/c terrible and so on and
then you know in the newspaper and the
LA Times in the Metro section they would
lead they would show restaurant closures
and why and I had always kind of read
that wow vermin infestation
and things like that so that yeah right
so and then it you'd see Pico Boulevard
wait have I been to this place but I
don't know I just found it to be like a
really interesting character I mean and
ripe for so many things from like humor
which David got to you know kind of this
quality of a whole business like
something like this at the mercy of this
one person who could be having a bad day
or could be just you know honest at the
job and trying to keep people healthy
but I that was one of the things that
was the most interesting to me about the
movie was that job and the character
that David played this place as an egg
for the record right I also wanted to
ask about the music component too
because I I'm a high school band geek
and I love that element of it so are you
a music fan before signing on to this
and what do you have to learn to be a
convincing music conductor because it
just really appreciated like the bounce
in your movement which stood out from
the teachers that I had I actually don't
play any instruments
that's not sure I did the bay I've
learned how to play the bass clarinet in
high school my step dad is a musician so
I grew up with a lot of instruments
around the house but I never wanted to
take anything on because I thought if I
did he would make me rehearse all the
time and that's just not a life I was
trying to live in the elementary school
or high school if you will but um for
the conducting itself we had somebody
show me the moves and then we just
wanted to add this lively element to it
because there is such a contrast there
too you know before being before jail
and afterwards and so I went to a good
old YouTube and watched a bunch of
videos and took things that I thought
you know would work for Veronica and
yeah actually Adam for one of my
auditions made me conduct for him
yes throwing him under the bus there
before I had before I had proper
training but I did it I think it was
fine
what kind of like compared to the
finished product no I don't I think that
was really really exciting was just this
idea that there
real dance to her and she really you
know makes it very very alive and you
can kind of see in terms of what happens
in the film I mean we actually cut back
on that because it we went further in
the film in terms of the the power of
that because it seemed but it's it's
it's very she really really loses
herself in the music and that is a
contrast to the other side that we see
where she's actually punishing herself
for having lost maybe become too
impulsive and really she's a character
who lets herself make impulsive
decisions and that that really is one of
the things that she's kind of punishing
herself for I don't give away too much
of the plot it's a lot growing up so I
think that that was it was easier to add
you know that the bounce if you will i
mean ii think you know it's interesting
when you were asking about because the
one thing as a director you never you
never get to see other people direct so
I have no idea what happens on other
people's sets everything that they're
saying I just think well that's what a
director should normally do I mean if
you're not there to listen and to
actually observe these amazing
performances I'm not quite sure what
directors do but I do know that I'm
right beside the camera which flips a
lot of younger actors out because
they're not used to that directors are
usually behind a monitor but I just want
to be there and and to absorb what
they're giving me I'm also writing the
script so it's a huge it's it's Anna
have to cut about time it's like just to
contain my excitement because they're
able to finesse it and bring saturated
with the humanity that I was praying for
but they're able to bring and and if I'm
a small part of that then I mean
I mean I'm not trying to humble I mean
obviously it's it's it's you have a lot
of control over it but it just feels
that they are the ones who own these
characters like when when Rossum was you
know talking about you know he really
embraced a side of the character that
maybe I didn't really understand and was
prepared to go with just because he was
so passionate about it and you know
remember when Lou came and realized that
he you know you you you felt that this
character could have been done in one
day but we had like three days just
because it's just it felt that you want
to allow time and to you know what we
had the discussions we had and and in
terms of like working with David it's
just like you know seeing a performance
in your in your life that just changes
you and dreaming of working with that
actor and having them respond to his
script and having that meeting in London
and just realizing that my god this is
gonna come true it's just so thrilling
and I'm so Frank thankful for that going
back to something you said earlier in
that answer if you had the opportunity
to observe one other director for a day
who would you pick and why well it's
obvious because it's a mystery right I
mean Hitchcock is one of my favorite
directors but what he says about working
with doctors seems so it doesn't seem to
connect with the performances you get
right you know so I'd like to actually
understand what he was like on set
because it he there's no way he could be
as removed as he would allow us to
believe he said that shooting was what
you know he has some famous statements
about actors which I'm not gonna repeat
because they just don't seem to make
sense given the complexity of the
performances so I would love to have
been on vertigo is one of my favorite
films I would have loved to have been in
that scene where where you know there's
a scene in a shoe store with with James
Stewart where there was where she's
trying to Novak is trying on these
dresses and he becomes so obsessive it's
actually one of the best scenes about
directing I've ever seen because he he's
directing her right he wants her to wear
this particular dress and there's no way
that you could have gotten that
performance without an amazing dialogue
between the actor and the director so I
would have loved to have been on that
particular set that particular day
speaking of amazing dialogue you
definitely have someone here some here
and I want to ask you too about getting
a whole
material especially because it's a
nonlinear story about I mean basically
exposition explaining your past but
making it more than you know the
exposition dump so to speak so I imagine
it must be daunting to get a whole you
know pages worth the material saying
this is how you're going to explain your
past so how do you give that kind of
that that extra degree of life so it
doesn't feel like that we had a lot of
time to rehearse so we went in and
fine-tuned everything and I think the
important thing was just to figure out
what I was thinking when I was you know
saying the lines that I was saying so
the in terms of memorizing and it wasn't
hard at all because there was such a big
rehearsal process it was kind of I mean
definitely you know you see a script and
it can be a little daunting like okay
how am I gonna learn this and but I
would just kind of have the idea that he
is a priest and he does sit and talk
with people like a psychiatrist you know
or a doctor or a therapist and they go
through their lives and their histories
and while also you know like you were
saying it's it well also what Adam was
saying it's kind of the spine of the
movie it's almost like a voiceover but
you're seeing the people while they're
speaking and so that kind of helped me
to relax to just think about you know
this is a priest and he you know as a
man of the cloth does speak to people
about you know these kind of things that
are unknown to other people and possibly
secrets and you know things that you
know you would never tell anybody else
so there was kind of a thoughtful
quality and that's where it was great to
work with both of them on those scenes
because it it came very naturally but I
do know what you mean about sometimes if
you feel like gosh they've they've got
me saying plot points here you know so
that you help the movie along but that
just wasn't the case here where it was
just it it it came very fluidly I mean
there is this big mystery which is a
Jim's character has asked
to have the funeral of this particular
church and at the beginning of the film
it's clear that he's never set foot in
this church he's not so so there's a
mystery and there's certainly a sense at
a certain point where we understand that
Luke's character knows the history and
as she begins to explain because he
wants to know some stories about Jim
because he has to prepare eulogy
so she's he's asking the daughter and it
will tell me something about your father
and as she does and it's mysterious at
what point in the film but he begins to
understand that he knows this this
narrative and it's had a huge effect on
his character and it's had a monumental
effect on on Jim's character so there's
this other energy it's not it's this
scene is not what it seems but it's
never made clear where that point of
recognition is I mean I think we've
identified it but you'd have to see the
film it's quite subtle to understand but
but Luke is processing that and then
eventually of course licensed character
has to understand the consequences of
that choice the father has made quite it
sounds complicated when I I mean it's so
difficult me more that when you explain
it it does sound complicated but when I
watch the movie it all comes together so
perfectly that's what you hold something
with the exposition to is it works
because it feels like the story you've
crafted it was necessary to have the
nonlinear storyline I mean a film called
Sweet Hereafter and the continuity
person said you know there are actually
in this breakdown like 8 different days
that this bus is traveling and I went
okay but I I don't think anyone's going
to actually acknowledge that so if we
begin to actually detail that it's just
good so it's the same thing here I
actually am one of the things I'm I have
to say I think this there's a there's a
simplicity to this film and and you
don't lose yourself you know but except
when you hear the director talking about
I have to end on a somewhat silly
question because this is another thing
that really stuck out in the movie to me
because I am a major pet lover and
naming my pet is like one of the most
important things in the world so do any
of you have pets what are their names
and why did you choose that name
I like to say I've had rabbits ever
since eh okay I can name all of them but
I will I've had like ten different
rabbits I have a dog that I'm obsessed
with she came to said they wrapped her
out her name's Lua
she which means moon and Portuguese
she's a little over one she's a rescue
she's not with me on this trip and I'm
struggling a lot but I think I'll
survive I know I didn't bring her but we
maybe maybe talked about putting her in
the movie she didn't get a part but you
know me a little dog named half-mask
she was she was named by the breeder cuz
she's half gray and half black and we
call her half see I only ever had one
pair and it was a rabbit and it was
called lip-smacking cool talk in a tasty
motivating good Buzzard whispers in hi
walk in thirst-quenching life is in Nice
fizzing good buzz in ever live in Pepsi
there was a Pepsi Cola advert in Britain
with that and that's what my run is gone
and it had an unfortunate end it escaped
dog she recently passed away just a
couple months ago a name was spelt -
which in French means everywhere and my
mother named her path - because I
couldn't figure out a name for I used to
just call her a cave and my she'd used
to go she used to go everywhere with me
actually I'd bring her into restaurants
like this in a bag
and anyway everywhere well my cat deputy
Dewey who was named after scream back in
LA says thank you to you all for your
time today thank you everybody out there
watching do not leave this video without
liking and sharing it and keep an eye
out for guests of honor and more at tip
2019 coverage coming your way real soon